hello my name is Yan Perko I work for
Wolfram research and today I'm going to
talk about cloud notebooks what you can
do with them and what we've been working
on over the past year
okay let's get started hello and welcome
my name is Yan I work on cloud notebooks
and today I want to talk about what's
new in in our world but first of all I
want to introduce the concept of cloud
notebooks in general so probably
familiar with notebooks in desktop
Mathematica we have your local
installation of symbol from system and
you work with notebooks to create
documents to your computations and so on
and our goal is to bring that same power
that same concept of notebooks to the
web so that you can on the one hand edit
notebooks just in a web browser but on
the other hand and that's maybe even
more interesting to deploy notebooks to
the web so that other people can can
look at them and can interact with your
notebooks again this is the idea is that
you don't need any local installation of
Mathematica or anything there's no
plug-in running in your browser it's
basically just a website and by the way
this is also a cloud notebook so I'm
running chrome here is my web browser
and it's connected to a local private
cloud you could say it would work pretty
much the same on Wolfram cloud com just
that I want to wanted to make sure that
we don't run into any network issues and
also I'll show some features that are
not shaped to the public cloud yet so
that's why i'm i'm using my local
version so that's a notebook in
slideshow mode and as usual you can type
things here some text or some
computation and then when you press
shift enter you get back a result you
can do more complex stuff of course it's
connected to a kernel running on a
server in the Wolfram cloud in this case
on my computer so you can do some math
and if you get back some more complex
formula it renders right in your browser
using our JavaScript from the ends
basically and this is also not an image
so if I exit
full screen mode here and resize the
window this will resize accordingly
intent and line wrap right we have
support for graphics both
two-dimensional and three-dimensional so
if you have something like this you can
take this and rotate it interactively
and of course we support various
interactive user interface elements of
of notebooks so in simple case it could
be like a button here that when you
press it prints a large number but you
can build more more complex user
interfaces either using low level
constructs like button and dynamic
module and so on order is a very nice
high level sort of function that that
constructs user interfaces for you just
manipulate so if you do something like
this you get back a manipulate that is
interactive right in my browser now can
drag the sliders I can move around
locators and it just works so that's the
general idea of cloud notebooks and I
wanna highlight some things that have
happened over the past year or so and
very big focus of ours has certainly
been stability to make the whole system
more robust so a few things you
shouldn't see anymore now is this
warning it says that your session timed
out and then you had to refresh the
whole page there was a bit annoying
there was also problem where if you kept
the manipulated open for a long time
sometimes you got initialization timed
out and they all had to do basically
with the client and the server getting
out of sync after a while and then there
was no good way for them to communicate
anymore
not they were actually separate issues
and and really not trivial to solve but
I think we did now and and so these
problems should be should be gone now
and of course we're making various
improvements to make all of notebook
rendering more robust but we realized
that there's probably always gonna be
some limit of what you can do in a web
browser because after all it's a very
hostile environment to do this sort of
stuff in JavaScript and but but then we
just want to make sure that even if one
cell is maybe problematic you can still
view the rest of the notebook at least
or even better we might want to try to
show the cell but it's just not going to
be interactive so the idea is that if we
if you have a very large cell or very
complex one we detect that and so in
this case it's it's hitting the output
size limiter first which you might know
from from desktop Mathematica but once I
press show all here to basically render
3000 buttons it's gonna give up on on
trying to render that interactively and
just render an image instead which is
generated on the server where we have a
bit more power and then rendering an
image is is easy on the browser so it
you know it won't it won't kill your
your browser tap and so on so the nice
thing is that you can still see the
buttons but unfortunately won't be
interact with them in this way once you
try to do that then you click here it
will tell you the time but it will tell
you that the cell contents are too large
for for interactive rendering and if
you're brave and courageous you can you
could click try to render anyway taking
the risk that it might freeze your
browser or at least the one tab might
take a while you can also stop this but
in this case it wasn't even too bad it
comes back with the interactive result
buttons don't do anything but at least
you can see the hover effect so
was or will be one way in the upcoming
version of the cloud how we try to make
notebooks more robust and you know at
least showing you something as already
said we're constantly working on
performance as well one aspect of this
is that we're trying to show you the
notebook as as soon as possible and way
how we address that is that we generate
static HTML on the server that we can
ship to the client immediately as you
open the notebook
and the client that is the browser can
render that very quickly but in the
background it will download all the
necessary JavaScript and then execute
that to render the notebook
interactively so the point is again that
you see something right away like any
other web page basically but then it
might take a little bit for it to become
interactive and we've had this system in
place for a while and made various
iterations on it improving it so it
should be quite robust now one thing
that you might still sometimes see is a
small difference between the HTML that's
generated on the server versus the thing
that's produced on the client-side and
that's when you get things shifting
around a bit as the notebook loads this
is exactly what what what we're working
on improving to minimize these these
differences between what we call the
cache and the live version so that's in
terms of free rendering of notebooks
also we're constantly working on our
JavaScript code to make it faster to
optimize how how we render stuff in the
browser so just did a recent
optimization that at least for certain
POC structures brings down the rendering
time to about thirty percent of what it
used to be so three times as fast and
just probably I think over the last year
we've made even even more like this so I
think it
have to say that it got faster by a
pretty good factor and then on a
slightly higher level it's also
important particularly a cloud to think
about the network so in in the desktop
version you don't really have that
problem because the front-end and the
kernel usually run on the same machine
so any transaction between them is
pretty fast usually the computation
itself is the bottleneck but in the
cloud you know every time we talk to the
kernel from the client you need to make
a network request and that has a big
latency usually so we thought would make
sense is to try to batch multiple
evaluations into one single HTTP request
to not only get hit by the latency once
and one example you could see this is if
you have a list of many dynamics they
basically want to try to resolve at the
same time but what used to happen is
that they would really go one after
another and waiting for the previous
request to complete but now this should
be almost instant and maybe it's a bit
cheating because I'm running on a local
machine of course but you can see this
what in what we called a notebook dev
tools you can open them with a special
keystroke and then you have get a list
of everything that goes on between
client and server particularly the
evaluations so if I make a change now
you will see it makes one evaluation for
the hotel and then it made three
subsequent evaluations to resolve these
50 dynamics it's a bit non-deterministic
depending on how rendering catches up
with network requests but it's usually
going to be much less than the number of
dynamics and maybe this is a bit of a
contrived example but it will be very
useful for for typical manipulate
as well they have probably have a lot of
controls that all at least need to
initialize once and now that can all
happen with a single or at least a few
network requests all right even more a
long optimisation and this one is really
highly experimental but I think it's
pretty exciting so I wanted to show you
this here the idea is that we get rid of
the network request completely it is
that you can create a manipulate and we
compile the body of the manipulate into
web assembly using the upcoming compiler
technology for the Wolfram language and
so then the browser can can update the
manipulate without going back to the
server and the kernel this is just in my
computer I need to enable to enable it
with this flag but then once we create
manipulate might take a little longer
because the compilation initially yeah
so you've tools you should see it's it's
pretty smooth I mean maybe not as nice
as a desktop yet but very comparable I
would say and this would the nice thing
is that this would work just the same on
Wolfram cloud comm because this is not
you know not getting any advantage from
from running on my local machine oh and
as you can also see here in the dev
tools
there's no not a single request coming
from the client to the server it's just
updating it on the client side
we made this work for a very special
case of manipulate where you have plot
of a function that we can compile and I
think for that it's probably good enough
that we can ship this as soon as the
compiler is ready but then we'll have to
think about how to generalize that that
will probably not be not be easy but at
least for certain manipulates you can
you can expect the good speed up from
this
from very bold optimizations to some
design details that we've been working
on we've been working on on all the
controls updating their design taking
care of little things like making sure
that the buttons stay in their pressed
state while the evaluation is going to
give you more feedback some people have
asked for that and also working on
better rendering of what we call
growable characters like when you have a
radical and something inside you know it
depends on how large that thing inside
is of course if I resize the circle the
radical resizes as well and we had this
before but what we were doing is we were
stitching together many many little
characters and sometimes you could see
artifacts from that and until a sin
comes in and so on and and it was also
slower because the browser had to do
more more stuff but now we're creating a
single path and using SVG to render this
whole thing another little detail also
using SVG rendering now is cell brackets
maybe if you are using a high resolution
to put display you might notice that
these look much better now and we
support things like you know there's
decorations of cell brackets in this
case for the traditional form it's very
hard to see but you get a little dotted
border as well another feature that's
coming soon is dynamic Geographics where
we figured for this particular thing it
makes sense not to use the whole box
rendering stack that would be used by a
test of Mathematica but you have our own
custom JavaScript implementation for
from apps okay
so there you have a map with some
polygons on top of it and you can
interact with this pain around zoom in
and so on and this is this is working in
cloud notebooks now I think the function
is still experimental anyway but if you
want to start using maps in notebooks
that's probably an interesting thing
finally I want to talk a little bit
about typesetting
in relation to the editor and the sad
news is that we don't support it yet
completely so you know in desktop
Mathematica you have a very nice editor
we can enter subscript superscripts
fractions grids and so on
we're still working on the foundation to
make that happen in in web browsers as
well it's just not not easy at all but
in the meanwhile I thought I'd show a
few things how you could sort of work
around that and one thing we've had for
a while I think is a way to convert from
input form to standard form so input
form is a thing where I would just type
X /y
whereas in standard form this turns into
a fraction an actual typeset fraction
and this is in the sell gear menu under
convert to standard form and derogate a
fraction so that's nice if you have a
single you know a whole cell that
contains some math that you could
represent this way but I can't even take
this now so I can select the cell
bracket and then press command C to copy
it to the clipboard and it could paste
this anywhere else for instance in a new
input cell and then I can can also edit
around that so I can have something like
this I can paste it another time I just
can't cursor inside of this construct it
stays as an atomic blob but I can delete
it as a whole if I want to and the nice
thing is that this has of course that
the right semantics so if I evaluate
this it realizes this is not just an
image or anything but it it is actually
the fraction x over Y we don't yet but
that's also coming yeah that would help
with this too
evaluate the place yes so that would do
the other way and we're just about to
hook up shortcuts for this as well you
don't have them yet because it's again a
bit tricky in the browser it won't let
us use the ones we want but we'll find
other ones
another thing that's coming probably not
too soon but not too far away either I
hope is a way to input tech code which
probably many people are familiar with
and that's that's also a nice way to
write formula and it's also not it's
also easier for us because we only have
to worry about a linear input string as
opposed to this 2d typeset typesetting
editor so the idea is that you press
command for or command dollar and then
you get this little input field
similarly to control equals for
linguistic input and here I can now type
backslash fraction XY and when I resolve
it it also turns into the typeset
construct and again this has the right
semantics of course so that's that's
kind of becoming as well I think this
will probably land in the cloud first
because it's more important for us
because there is no other good way to
input typesetting constructs but I think
it is definitely planned for desktop as
well I think it will be a nice features
in it should yeah
yep huh and yep that's a few things
we've been working on it's a very active
area of development so I couldn't show
everything here's a few related talks
about the compiler if you're interested
in that or just other front-ends or
notebooks in general and a shameless
blog if you're interested in more
practical applications of cloud
notebooks and how to build something
like a blog with them I'll do another
talk on Friday about that thank you very
much
[Applause]